[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is shocking you are excelling in
math that's surprising not surprising
shocking okay I really thought this was
gonna be a meeting where I have to tell
you how close you are to flunking out
why would you think that the point is
with scores like this you can pretty
much call your own shot you want to go
into pre-med make that happen you want
to be a lawyer
law schools on your horizon what about
accounting maybe that's what you want to
do with your life actually I want to
talk about fantasy football for a living
fantasy football is something you talk
about with your friends you do have
friends right what it's not a career I'm
gonna talk about it on TV TV okay or I'm
gonna talk about it on the Internet I'm
gonna talk about fantasy football on the
Internet
Wow that's a that's a crazy idea huh
what else is gonna happen on the
Internet oh maybe Martin Scorsese will
make a movie that you can only watch on
the Internet
is that gonna happen - yeah pretty much
this show is gonna be on the internet
it's gonna be in Las Vegas I'm gonna
take questions from the audience I'm
gonna take questions from celebrities
we're gonna complain about coaches we're
gonna have injury updates I'm gonna give
sleepers out so woman will come on every
week for some reason at the end she'll
say bye I'm gonna have a coach looks
like you without the ridiculous hair
we'll talk about fantasy football
every single weekend is this gonna
happen right now on your fantasy fire
drill
why from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas it's your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
[Music]
[Applause]
hey no I got one more week four more
week Thanks hey everybody this is it
this is the last one of the year this is
your fantasy fire drill hi I'm Matt
camping thank you for being with us all
season long Congrats if you have made it
this far that is an achievement and if
you're with me because of that well you
did it as well but if you're just
watching for a little entertainment
because your season's over
thank you thank you to everybody who's
been with us all season long as soon as
the show's over I'll still be jumping in
the app for another 30 minutes this is
our last show I still got two more weeks
of articles coming out so don't worry we
got you covered there but most
importantly we have you covered here
live in Caesars at the sports book once
again for your fantasy fire Joel we'll
get to injuries inactives will get you
sleepers I got a campfire talk one more
Matt moment all to come so let's jump
into what we got injuries to get to I
know your season might be on the line
will you have these players in your
lineup though that is the question we'll
get it going here right away Jordan
Howard is out today for the Philadelphia
Eagles now I know Boston Scott stepped
in and was the best Eagles running back
last week cuz miles Sanders was banged
up during the game I still like Sanders
more he's a solid RB to will fuller here
for the Houston Texans is in today he's
gonna play now I don't love him I think
the Tennessee defense on the back end is
a little bit overrated so I think you
could take a shot on him but he's more
of a risky play Adam Humphries is still
out for the Tennessee Titans now that
means AJ Brown who we gave you as a
sleeper last week wide receiver to
overall by the way in week number 14 you
could continue to play him with
confidence now Derek Henry we don't have
an official word yet he hasn't practiced
all week but he is expected to play you
have to play him the Titans decided to
play it smart with him and not put him
out there and practice knowings a little
bit banged up but we know he's been
outstanding the season could end up
leading the NFL in rushing
Devante Parker is gonna be good today he
was activated off the concussion
protocol he's good to go there we'll be
back in your lineup he's a wide receiver
- and a good one at that Evan Engram and
Daniel Jones are both out for the Giants
we know that for a fact so Eli Manning
is back in the lineup and Eli Manning
guess what Darius late complete with
anybody you could play him with
confidence hopefully safe one Bart they
can get back to the level that we need
no offense is expected to play today and
he's in fact definitely in today we gave
you him last
sleeper tight-end number two for week
number 14 he's got the Chiefs it's
snowing we'll talk about that coming up
in a little bit because that's doing one
of my sleepers Damian Williams for the
Chiefs don't have an official word but
he is not expected to play today for the
Chiefs now that makes it a little bit
easier to start LeSean McCoy but he's a
low-end RB two at best rather have McCoy
as a flex Jimmy Graham's gonna be in
today for the Green Bay Packers he is
banged up you haven't been using him but
if he was out of the mix that would have
taken some targets away from him
obviously not the case you're still
playing Davante Adams there now more
early game inactives
and injuries that we know about right
now both Scarborough is out officially
saying for the lines now don't worry
about that backfield today don't go
after it
next week though despite the fact that
the Lions are out of contention
carrion Johnson is expected to return
carrion Johnson could give you a big
boost of the fantasy championship you
can cut both Scarboro loose by the way
Edelman not officially in yet he should
be out there same thing with some new
elements the only Patriot you're
literally playing with a lot of
confidence Greg Olson is out we gave Ian
Thomas last week I'm giving to him again
this week had to touch that last week
came through they certainly need them
against the Seahawks does that Ian
Thomas Winston's gonna be in there but
Mike Evans will not be so this should be
a big Chris Godwin week and Winston
remains as we know a bunch of picks
bunch of touchdowns he's in there and
you're gonna play him once again as a
top 10 quarterback so that's where we're
at for our early games as of right now
but now your late games injuries that we
know about Alex Madison is out today so
you're always playing Dalvin cook but
maybe you're willing to pay up for him
in DFS against the Chargers because you
don't have mad Madison's stealing any
touches away from them DJ Starks gonna
be out and we not mean them a ton see DJ
chart for the rest of the season
I do like DD Westbrook today hunter
Renfro is down for the Raiders we do
know that what we don't know officially
is Josh Jacobs now all indications are
he is going to play he has said that all
week
is he a hundred percent far from it the
Andre Washington stepped in last week
did a good job I think we'll see some of
Washington even what Jacobs expected to
play I would throw Jacobs more towards
the end of the RB to tear and the Gerald
Everett's going to be out again and
Tyler Higbee
we love when sleepers graduate the
starters he is definitely in the
ten potentially a top-five tight end the
Rams are playing better football we like
to match with Donald last week he got
concussed he's not gonna play today and
neither is juju and I'll tell you right
now if you're hurting for a roster spot
you might just cut this guy loose
because I don't know if he's gonna be
back next week at James Connor it looks
like he'll be back but I do not throw
them in the rb1 conversation even though
you may have drafted miss such I was a
long time ago at ey Hilton is a true
gametime decision for Monday Night
Football so don't assume he plays get
them in your Flex spot maybe a pivot to
someone like Zach Pascal that's a
potential there now
we'll get to more of the injuries when
we have the updates later on but first
we get to a lot of your questions here
for a week 15 explore Melvin Gordon on
PPR nine people are lean towards Gordon
love both of these guys that's a tough
question they're next up Gallup or
Darius Slaton I'm gonna go Gallup there
against the Rams it doesn't scare me to
off too much and gals been playing some
pretty solid football so we go him over
Slayton feel interlocked at both guys
who noticed evil or not on the injury
report he's good to go but so is Lockett
both guys often I have more trust in
Lockett I'm gonna play him today nice
spot to be in dak Kyler or Fitzpatrick
playing against Lamar I'm gonna go dak
Prescott against the Rams that matchup
doesn't scare me off too much need a
flex James life or Cincinnati or he
motion against Atlanta I love Kyle
Shanahan caring about our fantasy teams
and saying most dirt has earned the job
so I now constantly tell you to play a
team oh sure tamal Williams Chris
Thompson or Zack Pascal will take a shot
on Pascal just because we don't know a
bell hit Hilton for Monday Night
Football to the wall we go for a viewer
question hey coach your GM TJ here I
want to see after all these years of the
free tutelage I've given you to see if
you've learned anything my question to
you do we start Kenyan Drake this week
or a healthy James Connor this is a big
one for people
let's see what you got coach come on up
here cuz apparently this is going to you
you learn some annecy from this guy Jay
that guy taught me how to play fantasy
football good man you know what I taught
him in return
what's that I taught him how to read and
now he's got a wife and I live at the Y
here's what I'm saying Kenyan Drake
write Kenyan Drake gotta play him cuz
Conner we don't need this no no they're
gonna use everybody I'm gonna play
Kenyan Drake TJ you're gonna win love
you baby
good luck at the Y buddy all right there
you go there's a one of our questions
from the wall now it's time for some
campfire talking you may already know
where I'm going with this when I talk
about the injuries we're saying see you
later
to the injured players guys that have
gone on IR this week Darius guys Marvin
Jones more of coming obviously we don't
have Mike Evans or DJ chart this week
they're saying AJ Green could be back
who knows about it but look at all the
teams that have disappeared this week
and probably more are coming I would
just say this if you have Flyers
prominent players on your team on teams
out of contention and they get a little
bit banged up this week they could be
going to the IR why risk it the kalman
relieves in that conversation and
that'll lead us to one of our sleepers
coming up later on so these injured
players on teams out of contention if
anything else happens this week we could
be saying I don't know what's that
there's a way to send these guys off and
I kick
I don't know hey you might leave it to
the professional we gotta get rid of the
guys we lose the red leather yellow
leather red leather yellow leather
[Applause]
thank you hey that's the first time the
buy made sense it worked yes we're
waving goodbye to those players
hopefully don't get any more injuries
coming up this week but we probably will
but more of your questions though right
now let's go how do we help the people
get to the fantasy championship or the
title game here for weapon Mixon vs New
England or Sanders against Miami
I think the volume will be there for mix
if you want to play it safe Sanders your
up side play next up here
Tannehill R Wilson all can you imagine
me asking you this back in August am I
gonna play a Ryan Tannehill Russell
Wilson it's close I'm giving the slight
edge to Russell Wilson but there you go
a Tannehill that's we're out Amari
Cooper obj I'll go Cooper I know people
are worried about the matchup a little
bit don't move around enough I'll go
Cooper in a better situation overall
obviously my ap Connor are haunted pick
two we got to play hon I like him a lot
this week he's been getting the job done
anyway and I'll go with Connor when in
doubt we'll go with a player on a
contending team I played David and Joe
Cory and Thomas well they're both
sleepers I'll tell you that right now
but David and Joe who has the Cardinals
he's the upside play a big E and Thomas
is a little bit safer which defense
Seattle or Casey I'll go with Seattle
against Carolina I know he's truck buddy
and Thomas but it's still Kyle Allen
back to the wall for another viewer
question hey Matt it's your old friend
the Unabomber and have I got a pickle
for you I have mild Sanders Austin
Eckler Devin Singletary
and rahim most ER I was checking your
rankings that are all neck-and-neck
so which three would you start unless
you would sit Courtland Sutton and play
all four of them standard scoring thanks
so much but longtime a friend of the
program Shawn they're good question and
he said one name that worried me enough
to tell you to sit down that's Devin
Singletary you have the Steelers you
have the bills two of the better defense
in the league playing each other
expecting a low-scoring affair not to
say Singletary won't get as touches I
just like everybody else a bit more so
I'm gonna tell you to sit down Devin
Singletary someone's got a heck of a
team there we're having someone benched
Devin Singletary in week 15 we got one
more of these it's our craziest one to
date here is your mat moment
[Music]
let me ask you a question should I start
Austin Eckler this week you have the
same questions every week it's Mark
Andrews going to play do I have negative
thoughts about any doll all I have are
negative thoughts about any doll
and said I want to be a professional
fantasy football guy everyone laughed
[Music]
you could say that again pal
[Music]
didn't know if I should even stream
coordinates
I show
starting to notice it's just one thing
introduce me it's fantasy football guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm a lost Phoenix brother what can I
tell you well you're looking for a hero
it's only one time it might only be once
it might be Ian Thomas I might have an
AJ Brown last week or Noah fanner Zach
Pascal maybe you're gonna stream a
quarterback that's okay you might have
your foundation players set in your
lineup for the fantasy semies for the
fantasy playoffs for the fantasy finals
next week but it could be that one
player that takes you to a championship
I want two championship with Matt Moore
with Derek Anderson guess what you could
gloat about that oh I had Patrica Holmes
oh that's great but we're gonna beat you
with that you know 18th ranked
quarterback sometimes that can work as
well so yes you can find that hero might
only take one time and maybe it's one of
these players are going to talk about
right now here are your week 15 sleepers
[Music]
alright here we go if you're streaming a
quarterback if you need that wide
receiver if you need a tight end I got
you covered here and we're gonna start
with a quarterback you're gonna say I
don't want to play this guy because it's
snowing like crazy in Kansas City and I
get that if you want to skip through
lock right now I get it but it is
snowing like crazy I will tell you one
thing it's tougher to back plena playing
defense than going forward because the
receivers know where they're gonna stuff
to get your footing going backwards a
drew Locke's playing real good football
right now he's got the Chiefs defense
which doesn't really scare me
I think he'll at least get garbage time
production I'm talking second
quarterback I'm talking cheap DFS place
you can go spend money elsewhere
drew Locke's got the confidence of his
team he will have no offense you will
have court and something who's playing
at a really high level and you know what
they got nothing to lose they might
chuck it 40 times today in the snow so
take a look at drew Locke now take a
look at this wide receiver I told you
that Calvin Ridley is done for the year
he put it up on his Instagram himself
the Falcons have a banged up Julio a
banged up Devonta Freeman that are gonna
be out there today but Russell gage
outside of last week when Ridley played
has actually been performing quite well
he's getting the target share the
Falcons are not very good there's more
targets out there they're throwing the
ball more and this is not out of nowhere
so if you need a wide receiver three
with some upside take a look at Russell
gauged a PPR I think the targets are
gonna be there seven eight targets very
likely coming his way and then tight end
brings it full circle just like this
outfit which I wore all the way back in
week one and maybe last night at our
dinner it's David and Joe ku David and
Joe who was probably drafted to be one
of the year I don't know seven or eight
best tight ends then he got hurt the
Browns are a mess and now they want to
bring Freddy kitchens back haul stuff I
don't care about that what I care about
is that he's got the Arizona Cardinals
he was on the injury report Wednesday
then he was good to go Thursday Friday
he's got the Cardinals we know OBJ's
playing hurt I'm gonna go one more time
we're gonna follow the Cardinals against
tight ends and we're gonna tell you to
play David in joke ooh now that article
will still be out the next two Fridays
and big board and all that but we'll get
to all of that then right now it's the
YouTube section hello YouTube one more
time I gotcha Covered Patrick or Drew
Brees I assume that's mahomes I feel a
little bit safer about drew Brees on
against the Colts next Melvin Gordon
Josh take up salbon Camaro this is
pretty easy I think you just sit down
Josh Jacob snowing he's far from 100% I
spot to be in there for a head feeling
or D but once again you want to play it
safe you just play debo knowing that
feeling still has that hamstring yes
it's done on the injury report but steps
one way the wrong way maybe he's done
again hunt or I think that's gala day
not holiday I'm gonna go with Kareem hug
there I like him a lot
he's been awesome since coming back from
his suspension next one up here Manuel
Sanders are Kenyan Drake I'm gonna go
Sanders here for the Niners a great game
last week and one in doubt let's go with
the team that's absolutely in contention
that is Emmanuel Sanders Z Kelly's
Barbie one do I roll with Melvin Gordon
Austin Eckler or bench one for Kareem
hunt I think I just stay with the
Chargers I know that's crazy but it's
one backfield that means a heck of a lot
now to the wall for a celebrity question
hi Matt it's Tim Brando merry Christmas
from the Chateau hey I know Tom Brady
hasn't been Brady like but he's got to
have enough to turn it up against the
Bengals right Tim Brando from the
Chateau hello what a Hall of Fame
broadcaster there and he's analyzing
this correctly Tom Brady's got the
Bengals on paper that's a good matchup
let's light up Tom Brady but can you
really do that this is not a reality
question I get it the Patriots are
probably gonna make it runs the
Superbowl again and that's fine but for
fantasy purposes Brady has not been good
he's a low-end starter at best I think
they can control that game with their
defense they win it like 24 13 kind of a
boarding game Brady doesn't have to have
a lot of volume so I would play guys
like Tannehill or Kyle Emery or Aaron
Rodgers or dak Prescott of the Winston
or any of those guys really over Tom
Brady thanks Tim for the questions now
we get back to the injuries what do we
know here for our early games they've
all updated information we know Jordan
Howard is out I go mile Sanders as an
rb2 well Fuller's in he's a real deep
reach I don't love them against the
Titans Adam comfort ease though is out
which means AJ Brown yes is a wide
receiver to and a strong one at that
Derrick Henry no surprise he will play
today after not practicing this week you
play him and Devante Parker cleared from
this concussion yesterday he's in there
he's a strong wide receiver to he just
got paid by the way Ingram and Jones are
down
yes Slayton is good to go
I would throw them in there again hope
for the best why not the Giants of the
Dolphins and then of course no offend is
back in this week in the weather there
the snow I'm not too worried about it
he's like a top 13 ish option Damian
Williams is out for the Chiefs so McCoy
makes it easier to start him low end RB
to though at best Jimmy Graham is in
thought maybe we eliminate him from the
mess that is the receiving corps outside
of Davante Adams in Green Bay but he'll
be in there today more of your early
game inactives that we know about both
Scarborough is out caught them loose
because carry on Johnson will be back
next week big boost there and Edelman is
in he's the only Patriot I think
everybody knows this that you can start
with confidence in fantasy big
difference between fantasy and reality
with the New England Patriots Greg
Olsen's out we like the in Thomas last
week we like him again this week in
Seattle Winston's in but Mike Evans is
out so it should be a massive Chris
Godwin game now late-game inactives and
injuries that we know about right now
Madison's out so you could pay up for
Dalvin cookies getting all the touches
DJ charkas out I do like TV Westbrook as
a result Renfro down but the bigger
question here is about Josh Jacobs all
in the case are he will play but how
much is the question Raiders are still
technically in contention for a playoff
spot so he's going to try and push it I
don't have him as an rb1 he's a mid to
low range RB to this week
Everett out which means Tyler Higbee is
a very good option going from sleeper to
starter we love that McDonald's out
Juju's out James Conner expected to play
but I don't put them in the RB 1
conversation I don't think he's fully
healthy and ready to jump in there at ey
Hilton is a true gametime decision so
get them in your flex spots you can
pivot off of him if need be I learned
that pivot word yesterday all right time
for the last speed round of the season
Oh God
[Music]
little bit left on the gas take
everybody this is the final speed round
of the season coach what do you have
left in the gas tank I got to tell you
something you might have to wait to
Christmas Tennessee Little Women but you
can watch these four bosses any time
lifetime I think I don't know Hallmark
Channel whatever whoo let's go to speed
round I'm a Dorothy you're a Blanche but
they were woods put you up to that my
archenemy all right let's go that's
Peter out of the season Baker cousins
two rivers
I gotta go Baker against the Cardinals
pretty good matchup there as we have
seen all season Eli are Brissette oh my
goodness someone might have to play one
of these guys we're gonna go for set
against the Saints Singletary Slayton
Gerlach it for the Flex we're gonna
throw a locker in there I think he's
good to go against Carolina hello
Montgomery Amendola Conley for the flex
will go Montgomery he does have the
Green Bay Packers not a bad matchup
there at all next one up here I need one
wide receiver one Flex Robinson would
Singletary moster old boy let's go woods
and let's go moster as much as I like
Allen Robinson I could softball in there
next up here Hooper or Henry I gotta go
hunter Henry double h get them in there
load them up next Kohinoor Singletary
don't love you do these guys too much
but we'll go with Singletary against the
Steelers Cooper gallop Slayton cup
Westbrook start three and one is
Affleck's who sits will sit down
Westbrook I like all these guys by the
way Cooper cups gonna finish off strong
yes what here might dark be impression
yeah it's over there though Shady Pines
ma Shady Pines
don't be going there to 220 anytime soon
obj Maclaurin Pascal or Slayton I'll say
you're gonna sit one let's sit Maclaurin
I don't really feel great about them
today Marlin Matt grant the new Miller
for my Flex spot Mack is safer against
the Colts maybe Miller if you're a big
underdog has big upside because he's
been getting a lot of targets standard
scoring pick to woods Kirk slate and
tape Pascal Woods is in and Kirk is in
against the Cleveland Browns and one
more let's see AJ Brown Zack Pascal hey
AJ Brown I came to you last week
I'll give them you two again this week
because Humphreys is out
one more let's do one down 40 points
Kyler Jimmy J Jimmy G baby let's fire
him up he got it done last week could be
on his way and leaving the Niners for
the NFC Championship that's it now
before I go you got something you can do
on Monday that's right the B are betting
blitz Monday 5 to 9:00 at the Vista
lounge at Caesars checking out Kelly
cabby Chad Johnson he's on the show here
he'll be there for you all fun stuff
coming your way go check it out enjoy
the cults and the Saints with these
wonderful people and thank to you
wonderful people who have been with us
all season long I've had a blast I'm
gonna get in that app and I'll take your
question for another 30 minutes Jason
and I just learned her name is Nicole
and only good all season want to thank
everybody behind the scenes and buddy
who's watched every made this happen New
York Las Vegas and all the people who
watch most importantly thank you now you
go look in week 15 and this has been
your fantasy fire drill
[Music]
[Applause]
you